my name is robbery guy Scofield I work
in the user interface department at
Wolfram and my talk is entitled Wolfram
player for iOS so I'm going to be giving
my talk using the Wolfram player app and
I'll start just by saying it's here in
beta so we've been working on this for a
very long time and we're very happy that
we've finally made it to this point
where we are ready for people outside
the company to start using the app start
testing it giving us some feedback so we
can finally wrap things up and get it on
to the App Store and on to all of our
customers iPads so our users have been
asking for this sort of thing a way to
view and interact with CDF documents on
iOS and more specifically on iPad and
that's what we are doing now so we'll
from player for iPad is available as of
today we are taking users names and
email addresses to get them signed up
and into the beta program so we can get
the beta app on their devices as soon as
possible we plan to make the app
available for free once it's finished
and the free app will display arbitrary
CDF documents statically which means not
really any of the dynamic interactivity
stuff if you have an Enterprise CDF
license and you create Enterprise CDF
files you can deploy those to Wolfram
Player for iOS and all the interactivity
will be there even in the free app and
we will have an optional in-app purchase
for a reasonable price yet to be
determined that will enable full dynamic
interactivity all the manipulates you
want in your CDF files on your iPad
during the beta period the in-app
purchase is not hooked up so all the
interactivity is going to be free during
the beta period
so this is a native app and one of the
most important things you can do with
this app is open your CDF files and
where do you get your CDF files anywhere
on the system if they come to you
through email you can tap on them in the
mail app and they will open up in
wolfram player you can open them from
dropbox from iCloud Drive you can
download them from the web anywhere that
you can interact with files on iOS
there's a way to get them into wolfram
player and on top of that it will
automatically sync with your Wolfram
cloud account if you log in so all of
your Wolfram cloud files will be there
things from Wolfram cloud com or things
that you save to the Wolfram cloud from
a desktop version of Mathematica and
that's the way that I made this
presentation for example because this
app doesn't allow editing it's just a
player so I you know wrote this document
on my laptop saved it 12th and cloud and
just opened it directly and here it is
so I'm gonna take a moment to show a few
of these things I'm going to drop out on
my presentation here I'm going to go
back to the home screen of the app I
have you know one file stored locally on
this device right now and I am logged in
to my Wolfram cloud account and here's
my Wolfram cloud files I can add another
Wolfram cloud account you can have an
arbitrary number of cloud accounts and
they can even be on different cloud
servers so if you are have an account on
the Wolfram cloud com that's where it
goes by default but if you have a
private cloud you can just change the
server that you're logging in to
multiple accounts it's very nice you can
import files from other data providers
on the system so right now I have just a
few of them I'm gonna click on iCloud
drive and I'm going to find a document
that I saved in my documents directory
on my laptop which sinks over iCloud
drive and it's in this folder here it is
I'm just going to tap on it and here it
is on my iPad
so this is a file that I downloaded from
the demonstrations project onto my
computer so we can do this other ways I
can drop out of the Wolfram player app
and I can go to Dropbox and I have some
a CDF file stored here
Dropbox doesn't know how to preview it
but I can export it from Dropbox and it
will ask me how do I want to open it I'm
going to open it in an app I'm gonna
choose wolfram player and there it is
okay and this is another file that I
just got from the demonstrations project
and I saved it to my Dropbox account and
then one more I'm gonna open up my email
here and somebody who happens to have
the identical name as me sent me a CDF
file an email and I want to see what's
in the CDF file so I'm just going to tap
on it and I'm going to choose import
with wolfram player and there we go
here's this file so it's very easy to
get your CDF files from anywhere on your
iPad any cloud storage service into the
app so you can view it and start
interacting with it right away
now I'm going to go back to my
presentation here which is stored on
Wolfram cloud comm alright so in
addition to all the ways directly on the
iPad that you can get files you can also
sync with iTunes and there's an
interface in iTunes where you can add
documents to the wolfram player app from
iTunes on your computer so some of the
nice things about this it supports local
computations so there is a Wolfram
kernel running on my iPad right now that
will handle all of the manipulate stuff
so when you change the sliders and
manipulate and the expressions
re-evaluating that's all happening
locally you don't need to be connected
to the network for this to work
being an iOS app we put a great deal of
attention into getting the right user
interface the right user experience for
this platform so one of the things that
means is that when we have buttons
hyperlinks controls all these sorts of
things
they all have touch targets that are
finger sized so you're not going to be
trying you know really hard to hit the
right thing because it was sized
for a very precise pointing device like
a mouse cursor on a laptop or desktop
all our controls are very large you can
touch them with your finger
we have pinch-to-zoom both in things
like 3d graphics but also in the
notebook as a whole so I can just pinch
and zoom this if I want to see part of
it larger and one of the important
things is that when we were dealing with
manipulates we discovered very quickly
that the default positioning of
manipulates that we use on desktop and
laptop computers with all of the
controls right above the content doesn't
work that well when you're doing the
interaction with your hands and you
touch the screen your hand covers all
the content if you if you're touching
right above it so what we've done is
we've taken these controls by default
and we put them at the bottom of the
screen so you're not covering any of the
content that you're trying to interact
with and I'll show you that in just a
moment but we have all of the features
that you would expect to find in CDF
files in Mathematica notebooks we have
typesetting it's very nice looking and
you can zoom in as far as you want and
it still looks very nice very high
resolution output from our typesetting
same goes for graphics we have very
nice-looking 2d graphics and also with
3d graphics as you've come to expect
from Mathematica and CDF player on the
desktop 3d graphics are rotatable so I
can take my finger and touch it and move
the graphic around and this one has some
nice transparency to it and it still
rotates very smoothly
one additional feature that we've added
to the specific
is that we can also take the graphic and
I can toss it and it will keep going
with until it will slow down and stop
eventually
we support the dynamic features that
you've come to expect in Mathematica
content so I can I have this checkbox
hooked up to a variable that is also
being used to control the background of
this graphic and when I change the
checkbox of graphics the graphic changes
as well and manipulate is built on top
of dynamic we support manipulate as well
and so this is a 3d graphic which I can
rotate and if I tap on it I get some
controls at the bottom of the screen
this one just has one slider I can take
the slider and I can drag the slider and
I can see my content change
appropriately so this was built for
touchscreens which means we needed to do
a few things differently things like
Mouse position don't make a whole lot of
sense in this case but we do have a new
function called touch position which
makes more sense and mouse position sort
supports one point because we only ever
have one Mouse on these desktop and
laptop computers
whereas on touchscreens I can have 10
possibly more points and so if I put my
finger on the screen if I put two down I
get two points in three and four and
five and I can just keep putting more
fingers down on the screen and get some
more points for that so you can do some
interesting things with the new touch
position function and if you need to do
something custom with the layout of
manipulate controls we support some new
functionality there as well if you have
controls that are very tall for example
and you don't necessarily want them at
the bottom of the screen because maybe
it would take up too much vertical space
we have a new option to manipulate
called touch screen control placement
and you can
move the touchscreen controls to
different sides of the screen so in this
case I have a vertical slider and rather
than taking up all of the space at the
bottom for this very tall thin thing I
just moved it over to the right side and
so here's my manipulate my controls are
over on the right side I have this
vertical slider and I can slide this and
the manipulate controls aren't covering
very much of the screen so I'll talk
real quick about the limitations some of
the limitations of this product as I
mentioned earlier it supports read-only
documents you cannot create new
documents you cannot edit documents this
is a player product wolfram player if
you want to create and edit documents on
an iPad we do have an app that's already
available called Wolfram cloud that does
just that well from cloud is good for
that sort of thing
the downside is that you do need to be
connected to the network because it is
communicating with Wolfram cloud comm in
order to do all of the work that it's
that the app does so the app is
relatively large it's a couple hundred
megabytes about the size of a you know a
typical game you would see these days it
does have a full Wolfram engine embedded
inside of it there's a handful of
features that aren't quite supported yet
some things like event handler don't
necessarily make a lot of sense
and some things like tab you we just
haven't finished yet and there are other
pieces of functionality things like J
link and database link which rely on
Java func Java language features and
functionality that simply will never be
available on iOS performance this is not
a desktop class computer but it's
getting closer and closer every year so
the CPU is a little bit slower but it's
acceptable in many cases and it has a
limited amount of RAM
and if you're John's talk you heard him
mentioned earlier that there's no
virtual memory on these devices so when
it's out of RAM the app just basically
gets killed by the operating system so
if you are doing computations that
require huge amounts of RAM that could
be a problem
you may need to to cut that back a
little bit and the newer Apple iPads
have more RAM than the older ones do so
newer devices are obviously going to
work a lot better for this sort of app
and the older devices other limitations
we don't currently support the option to
restart the wolfram engine the app
itself can be killed but the wolfram
engine can't be killed separately and
currently in the beta we're supporting
this for iPad only we have everything
ready to go on iPhones we just need to
work out some of the user interface user
experience issues dealing with the much
much smaller screen on phones than on
the iPad that's something that we expect
to support in the future but it is not
ready at this time so getting to the
details of the beta test we are inviting
conference attendees and premiere
service customers to beta-test wolfram
player for iOS there's a URL here which
you can make note of or perhaps get from
this notebook after the conference is
over is Wolfram comm slash iOS beta you
can go there to register for the beta
program it is going to be run through
Apple's test flight system which means
you will give us your name and email
address and through test flight you will
receive an email that with instructions
on how to get the app installed on your
iPad we are most interested in hearing
from you to know whether you encounter
any problems in the documents that you
view the sorts of things that were
not necessarily expecting but half
expecting maybe some crashes maybe some
rendering glitches things which don't
look the same on the iPad as they do on
the desktop computer or in cases where
the app has unexpectedly poor
performance not necessarily really
related to just being on a slower
machine with less RAM but something
that's you know really out of whack so
in such cases the most helpful thing to
us will be to actually have a copy of
the notebook or CD F file that displays
this sort of problem and if that's not
possible
you know we can work together to maybe
figure out a way to narrow it down a
little bit so that we can you know get a
reproducible case that we can test
against and fix so I'm just gonna click
on this link real quick I'm gonna open
it up in web browser and here's this
page it will describe a little bit about
the the beta test program and then has a
form at the bottom where you can enter
your name and email address so we can
compile all the people the testers
together get them entered into the test
flight system and get those instructions
sent out as soon as possible
so with that that is going to wrap up my
presentation and I'd be happy to answer
your questions if you have any
you